Alex Garland's Annihilation might be the prettiest
end-of-the-world movie you'll ever see.
Based on the novel of the same name by Jeff
VanderMeer, the movie tells the story of a
group of scientists venturing into a strange
quarantined zone called the Shimmer.
Inside, they encounter a surreal world that
seems to be remixing itself, and everything
in it.
The film juggles some heavy themes and has
a lot going on in its narrative, so by the
time it ends, it's a little difficult to unpack.
Let's break down the ending of Annihilation.
From a galaxy far away
The film's primary question is: "What is the
Shimmer?"
The film's opening shots show some sort of
interstellar object careening through Earth's
atmosphere and crashing into a lighthouse,
which becomes the prime destination for the
research and military expeditions into Area
X, which is what the land surrounding the
Shimmer comes to be known as.
The Shimmer, as it turns out, is some sort
of alien force.
It's either a thinking, living, breathing
thing, or a kind of celestial cancer, replicating
itself unconsciously.
Either way, its whole essence is ultimately
tied to an alien entity that we see take on
humanoid form in the film's closing moments.
Through the prism
Annihilation's second question is what does
the Shimmer do?
Determining this is the primary goal of Lena's
expedition.
Until her husband Kane came back, nobody who
entered the Shimmer ever returned, and he
seems to be sick, no longer fully in control
of himself, and clearly in pain.
With Kane out of commission, the Area X crew
still can't say for sure what happens in the
Shimmer, even after throwing team after team
into its clutches… until Lena and her crew
journey in.
Despite the way our protagonists are picked
off one-by-one, the Shimmer isn't an explicitly
destructive force.
The land inside isn't a ravaged wasteland,
but a lush, exotic forest filled with surreal
flora and animals that only resemble those
native to Earth.
The scientists discover that everything exposed
to the Shimmer is in a constant, accelerated
state of mutation, and that mutation isn't
confined to singular DNA sets.
Instead, the DNA is collectively jumbled up.
Animals become mixed with the plants; organic
and inorganic materials combine, connecting
all of nature in a very literal, very impossible
way.
"Do you think it's a cross-breed?"
"You can't cross-breed between different species."
The end times
It's established early on in the film that
the Shimmer is spreading.
As the scientists journey deeper into its
confines, we see that Area X's original headquarters
has been completely overtaken by the Shimmer.
Its threat is made abundantly clear by Jennifer
Jason Leigh's Doctor Ventress.
If it goes unchecked, the Shimmer will consume
the world.
Based on what we see, it'd be a gorgeous apocalypse
- but it's still an apocalypse.
While beautiful, the Shimmer is littered with
corpses and mutations, and filled with an
overwhelming sense of dread.
Humans in the Shimmer encounter violent ends,
like Anya's death in the jaws of a mutant
bear, or they give themselves over to it.
In humans, this DNA remixing leads to madness,
making them disoriented, agitated, and spaced
out.
The film never makes a statement on whether
the Shimmer's effects are a good or bad thing.
It simply presents them as an inevitability.
Face-to-face
Toward the film's climax, Lena encounters
Doctor Ventress, who has finally made it to
the Lighthouse.
However, Ventress has become a part of the
alien force that created the Shimmer, and
she soon transcends her human form and becomes
a sort of fractal prism herself.
After this prism absorbs a drop of Lena's
blood, it takes on a humanoid form.
In this moment, Lena effectively meets the
Shimmer.
While it initially seems malicious, the Shimmer
never actually sets out to harm Lena.
Instead, it just mirrors her movements.
It's an important moment that embodies the
goals of the Shimmer, it seeks understanding
and integration.
It assimilates to its environment; the mass
mutations and prism effect are the result.
Smashing the mirror
As her confrontation with the Shimmer creature
comes to a head, the creature, now in a humanoid
form and morphing into Lena, is given a grenade
by the real Lena: She places it in the Shimmer's
hands, pulls the pin, and runs.
As the grenade explodes, the Shimmer creature
catches fire; the lighthouse burns, destroying
the entirety of the Shimmer with it.
It cements the idea that the Shimmer is one
large collective being, and also allows Lena
the opportunity to escape and make her way
back to Area X.
Self-destruct sequence
Annihilation is a movie about destruction,
and the idea that deep in our genetic coding
there's a primal urge to destroy ourselves
and the world around us.
The Shimmer serves as an embodiment of that
inevitable urge.
It destroys what we have and turns it into
something new, for better or worse.
That penchant for self-destruction is explored
intensely through our protagonists.
Lena is a woman who ruins her marriage with
an affair, indirectly influencing her husband
to go on what is potentially a one-way mission.
Alma is a recovering addict.
Josie bears the scars of self-harm.
Ventress is dying of a cancer mutating her
insides, which informs her fascination with
the Shimmer.
These characters all have a subconscious wish
to end their lives, so their journeys ever
deeper into the Shimmer have an air of inevitability.
Even though Lena survives, she only does so
by destroying a doppelgänger of herself,
metaphorically wiping away her old identity
and emerging as something new.
Quarantine Q&A
Following her return from the Shimmer, Lena
is forced to take part in an extensive debriefing
about her journey while under a strict quarantine.
Is it the real Lena or a double?
After her time inside the Shimmer, the truth
is somewhere in between.
After her questioning, Lena is finally reunited
with Kane, who's no longer dying from the
Shimmer's effects, and even seems somewhat
lucid.
What Lena knows, and others don't, is that
it cannot possibly be him.
New me, new you
The most ambiguous moment of the film takes
place in its closing moments: Lena has known
since encountering her husband's remains at
the Lighthouse that whatever's back in the
Area X facility isn't him, but rather something
new.
Her being reunited with this Kane isn't quite
the moment those around her believe it is.
She knows the truth, and needs to tie up one
last loose end.
Reunited with Kane's doppelgänger, Lena asks
him if he's really her husband, and his answer
is not encouraging.
"I don't think so.
Are you Lena?"
Kane is something new, as well as the last
remaining fragment of the Shimmer, whether
he's fully aware of it or not.
In the film's haunting finale the two embrace
as both of their irises fluctuate and change
color, signaling the continuing mutation and
evolution caused by the Shimmer.
It now resides in Lena and Kane, who will
live on to change the world even further.
It might not happen soon, but the primal coding
that sends us toward self-destruction remains
as an inevitability that nobody, and nothing,
will ever fully escape.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!